[Musique]
je n'ai jamais vu de professeurs tenté
de faire passer un message politique ou
syndicale sur le dos des élèves et de
leurs familles ont créé un grand stress
pour un événement important en plus ça
va être très compliqué parce qu'il va y
avoir des recours il ya des élèves qui
auront le sentiment d'avoir été lésé
enfin tout ceci n'a pas de sens ce
n'était pas le bon moyen d'agir ça ne
changera rien c'est un coup d'épée dans
l'eau
d'un point de vue politique parce que ça
ne changera rien on peut parler du fond
de la réforme que nous aussi parfois sur
certains points nous pouvons contester
mais là il se trouve que l'islam est la
méthode est totalement déplorable et ça
concerne proportionnellement un petit
nombre d'enseignants mais ça a eu un
effet dévastateur et ce qui m'inquiète
le plus finalement c'est que ça
contribue à décrédibiliser et
l'éducation nationale et les professeurs
qui n'ont pas besoin de ça parce que on
voit bien aux concours de recrutement
il ya aujourd'hui des postes qui ne sont
pas pourvus le métier n'attire plus
comme ils attiraient autrefois ce pays
se plier et intoxiqué drogué à la taxe
à chaque fois qu'on a un problème mambé
une taxe là on va une fois de plus la
france qui est le champion du monde des
taxes et des impôts va mettre une taxe
supplémentaire ce qui est contraire à ce
qu'a promis le président de la
république et le premier ministre
puisqu'il avait dit à quelques temps il
y aura plus jamais de taxes mais y en a
une nouvelle et cette nouvelle elle lui
a quand même pénalisé air france est à
dire une compagnie française
cette taxe à nouveau c'est une grande
hypocrisie ça vient pour remplir les
poches percées de l'état et ça
n'arrangera absolument pas le climat
fiscalité comme seule arme pour aider au
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
c'est mauvais signal envoyé aux gens
parce que c'est les eris et parce que ça
vient impacter directement le pouvoir
d'achat dès aujourd'hui la france est en
train de se creuser pardonnez-moi sur le
poids des normes et prélèvements
obligatoires des taxes il n'y a pas de
fatalité à être le pays d'europe qui
aujourd'hui à la fois le déficit public
le plus élevé et le niveau des impôts le
plus élevé sans je pense qu'on est le
parti de la liberté
d'abord sonné le parti de l'autorité et
y
ils le parti au fond d' qui essayent
d'allier et qui arrive quand il est au
pouvoir
l'humanité nécessaire et l'autorité
indispensable donc c'est la force et la
justice c'est l'ordre et la justice
[Musique]